turning now to ukrainian president
voldemere zielinski and the tv show that
launched his political career we told
you about how his powerful address
yesterday to congress moved so many
lawmakers
many people learned zelinski's name
though after russia invaded his country
a few weeks ago but he is no stranger to
the spotlight he played a president in
the 2015 series servant of the people
before he was actually the real
president netflix streamed it here in
the united states and yesterday the
company announced it is bringing the
show back to the u.s by popular demand
it's about a teacher who unexpectedly
becomes the leader of ukraine and we've
got a scene for you he is i want to see
this yeah it's going to be good this is
an interesting method to calm down
fighting amongst his lawmakers watch
this
video
and they look over at him uh it was just
a joke and so this is a series that has
now been brought back to netflix and i
want to watch it guys but i'm also a
little i feel like i don't want to
i don't know a part of me says i don't
want to laugh because he's really the
president now and he's under this
existential threat and yet i'm going to
watch a show about him before all of
this where he plays a president who's
just limited enough you see it yeah i'm
just really curious yeah
someone said he's like the steve carrell
of ukraine yes yes um and you know i
talked to i only know one person from
ukraine her name is oxon i met her at
the food truck i told you about her and
she said that everybody not everybody
was on board with him yeah but now
everybody is on board with him he's
universally beloved and admired in that
he's doing it he's doing a terrific job
as a communicator i mean the skills he
brought as an actor and as a comedian
are clearly helping in the situation
he's in now and if he's got other
advisors around him it's working yeah
and you know it's just one of those
things that you know in in history you
will see people that you would not
imagine would rise to the occasion you'd
say he's an actor
and he you know he was on dancing with
the stars or whatever yeah and he won it
um but when faced with an existential
threat to his people he is race under
pressure it rises and he becomes an
inspirational leader yeah instead of
just playing one on tv